-Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys, it's Friday night!
The weekend is here.
It's time to check out
New York's newest hot spot
that's open all night long --
the Javits Center
mass vaccination site!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Ow-w!
-[ Imitates vuvuzela blasting ]
Yeah, since it's Friday,
let's kick off the weekend
with some good news.
For the first time
since the pandemic began,
a majority of Americans
now believe the COVID situation
in the United States
is getting better.
That's right, 60% of Americans
are feeling good.
Then, people realized today
was the last episode
of "Wandavision," and that
number dropped to less than 1%.
[ Laughter ]
But, still.
But, still, moods are
definitely improving.
Today, everyone's Apple Watch
was like, "Okay, superstar,
look who took 14 steps today.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Keep up the good work."
Yeah, we're all excited
for a future
that doesn't involve
Clorox-wiping our bananas.
[ Laughter ]
We might even have
a normal summer.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Like like there's a chance --
There's a chance I can be there
in a packed stadium
the next time Dr. Fauci
embarrasses himself
with that first pitch.
[ Laughter ]
-Aw.
-Bwuh-buh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't worry.
Why are you worried?
I would never --
I'm not going to show
your pitch.
I'm not going to show it.
-Okay.
-But our director, Alex, might.
-Hey, man!
[ Laughter ]
-Ah-bweh-weh.
Not quite. Alright.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ah!
[ Applause ]
-Not funny.
[ Laughter ]
-Not only are people
feeling better about COVID,
they're also feeling good
about President Biden.
A new AP poll puts his approval
rating at 60%.
We're living
through strange times.
60% approve of Biden
and 40% still believe Trump
is president.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Biden, yesterday,
he met with members of the House
to discuss jobs
and infrastructure
and I thought some
of his remarks
were pretty interesting.
Here, watch this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That's not all he said.
Later, this happened.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What?
[ Laughter ]
It's odd that he was just
talking about that,
but he said other things, too.
Listen.
[ Laughter ]
Here he is, talking about --
Here he is, talking
about the good old days.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Finally, he ended the meeting
by --
[ Laughter ]
by saying this --
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm just surprised
nobody stopped him.
That's just insane, you know?
Anyway.
Guys, Congress is getting close
to passing
its COVID relief bill,
but Republican Senator
John Kennedy
isn't supporting it and he used
a pretty strange phrase
to describe the bill.
Watch this.
-This feels dreadful.
Billions of dollars
to pension programs;
billions of dollars to schools,
with no requirement
that they open.
It's an orgy of pork.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
-If "orgy of pork"
sounds familiar,
that's because it's the
newest sandwich at Arby's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some more entertainment news.
I saw new photos
from the "Space Jam" sequel,
starring LeBron James
was just released.
But here's what's
making the headlines.
The director said that they
decided to make Lola Bunny
less sexualized
than in the first movie.
And, if you're upset about this,
take a cold shower
[ Laughter ]
and, while you're in there,
reevaluate your entire life.
[ Laughter ]
I just wish Tom Brokaw
hadn't retired
because I'd love to hear him
read this story, like --
[ As Brokaw ]
Cartoon vixen Lola Bunny
was redesigned
to reduce her sexual appeal.
[ Laughter ]
It's been a tough week
for conservatives.
They're like, "We just want
our bunnies sexy,
our children's books offensive,
and our potatoes with penises!"
[ Laughter ]
-Oh! Oh!
-And, finally, listen to this --
there are new photos
of a supersonic jet
that could someday fly
from New York City to London
in 90 minutes.
-Whoo!
-Check this thing out.
Look at that.
Yeah, it's 90 minutes in the air
to London,
and then another 90
to get spatula'd
out of your seat.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show, everyone!